mariah i'm so excited to talk to you
today thank you for joining us
thank you i'm excited as well
well you got to experience tribal
council which is an intense experience
what were you feeling the moment after
your torch got snuffed
so
i put
i was pretty sick at that tribal council
um
i really had to go to the bathroom
literally was i need to go to the
bathroom right now
um so moments after that i
i
i kept hearing my let my son dylan um
who's also a super fan he's like you at
least take the merge mom
and i i felt a little sad about that
like ah you know i'm gonna have to tell
them
i didn't make them urge
i know
but i i'm sure he's proud of you for
even being out there and getting to the
the second episode i think that lasting
any day on survivor is such an
achievement
and
i think for your case in particular we
got to see something really cool which
was it was the second episode we've
already seen the second shot in the dark
played
was there a moment at camp that made you
realize you needed to play your shot in
the dark
yes there were um two so leading up uh
it was really the last
you know 15 minutes half hour
um
we're packing to go to tribal council
and
lindsay i can still see her she's
bending over doing something and she she
winked at me
and that's it was so out of charac
that's just not what i
gleaned from her character so far it
just it seemed over the top too much
so it caused an eyebrow to raise but i
wasn't sure and then jonathan
came and laid down next to me in the
shelter
and he said i'm really gonna miss
marianne
and i was like okay
something's going on lady this is not
what you think it is you need to you
need to protect yourself so the
combination of those two things just
kind of gave it away
that's the thing i think it's sometimes
those little things where people could
think that they're doing something quite
slick that could be a tell so were you
surprised that it was a unanimous vote
and was there anybody on your tribe in
particular that you felt betrayed by
i betrayed i would say no because i
didn't how my alliance was with jackson
who was gone um the person that i was
the closest with
um
was omer and i i think
it was a struggle i couldn't see him
struggling at different points in a
couple conversations even at some
comments on at tribal that weren't shown
if
i doubt it at all i i felt like he was
actually almost apologizing like i said
something about like just wanting to um
part of my story wanting to advocate for
myself and make decisions for me instead
of other people
and he commented and and said uh
something like well we all have stories
right and i just i felt like he was
trying to say
i'm sorry you know but here's how it
goes but i wouldn't say betrayed i feel
like he came to play
and he played as he should and and i
think everyone in the tribe did so now
betrayal now
it's good to that you have that
perspective on it and i think from where
i'm sitting you had the right read on
the situation it just unfortunately
wasn't the right scroll this time
but speaking of the shot in the dark and
being in the dark let's talk about the
immunity challenge because you got to
play the classic survivor challenge
where you're blindfolded so what was it
like running that blindfolded challenge
and how did you decide who was going to
have which role
it it was um okay we practiced before um
before the challenge so there was
something that something came and i felt
like we had a clue
that we were gonna be blindfolded or
calling maybe not blindfolded so we
actually practice calling and yelling
out um
jonathan is he shared in the in the
premiere is not good at puzzles so we
were kind of looking at we didn't know
what all the challenge was going to
entail what kind of each other's
strengths and weaknesses
um
i think jonathan just had the loudest
voice just being you know so big that it
would just we would hear him
um
i do not remember how
uh omar and i ended up at the puzzle i
can't i really can't remember if he had
to did we volunteer i'm not really sure
how we ended up there
um the blindfold was really hard for me
erica like rick hard in your season i'm
actually deaf in my left ear so i rely
everything i'm relying on
the facial expression i mean the whole
mask it has been really hard and i'm
reading lips as as the whole thing i'm
just reading
and um
i've learned so i forget sometimes i
actually did i it was like it dawned on
me when the card said that on your
season i'm like oh yeah me too you know
but if someone is talking to me in their
back this to me i actually
you know i have to come around and i
have to ask them to repeat it so
i remember saying to elmer you go in
front
and you tell me what to do
and i followed i did not hear jonathan
barely at all jeff anyone else i was
listening to omar and i was saying
whatever he told me to do or following i
had my at one point i had my finger
hooked in his um pant loop and just you
want me to go and tell me what to do um
the puzzle was
was was just interesting and and a
challenging because that is not was not
jonathan's strength and so
he only wanted one of us to work and so
several times he would say mariah put
you take your hands off the puzzles
and um
it was just it's just frustrating when
you lose a sense you know just in
general you just you're you're totally
vulnerable to
whatever bumping into stuff or not
hearing or not seeing so it looks hard
it was really hard and exhilarating you
know i loved it at the same time
yeah i'm sure you got some bruises as
souvenirs too you had that real survivor
experience
yes
so the moment that i'm sure everybody is
asking you about is how you shared your
story and the story you shared about
your brother and i will say i watched
the episode in a room full of friends
and when you were telling your story
just shivers went down everybody's spine
so i want to say personally thank you
for telling that story so we all have
the opportunity to honor your brother
and i want to thank your brother for all
of his sacrifice and everything he's
done for his community so thank you for
sharing that and
were you really able to honor him and
were you able to bury that necklace
um well i'm wearing it right now
no no there you go spoiler
no i i yes i was able to honor him i
think even in your question and your
description of
his legacy
you know we're still talking about him
and it'll be two years on the 24th and
um
i want that always like i just he i just
you know i think i went and erica
looking for closure and i thought if i
buried it and you know because she
didn't have we didn't have a funeral and
now that's not
the goal anymore i don't want to close
the door on my brother i don't want
closure he's not physically here
um i want to figure out how to navigate
life
with him not physically here but in my
heart and spirit and everything that i
do so it's no longer the goal i don't
know you know i'll know
when i know if i'm ever very this would
do something like that but i am
absolutely content with
where i am right now
even though it looked different it looks
different than what i thought it would
be and what i thought was supposed to
happen there
well truly thank you for sharing i think
that when people go through these hard
times
i feel like people have expectations
about how they're supposed to handle it
but i think you just being so real out
there and being okay with how you know
your plan for honoring him it changed
and you're doing what's right for you
and truly thank you and thank you for
sharing that and thank you to your
family for letting you come out there to
share that
now
on twitter i told my followers that i
would be interviewing today so i had
some people submit questions for you
first
christopher asked um
what what are your biggest takeaways
from the game
um you know the biggest i might only get
to one because it's so involved with the
biggest biggest takeaway and i use this
as a tangible example not getting on the
boat
and they didn't show this scene but
marian and i both wanted to get on the
boat and um she's like i'm going to get
on the boat and i said i want to get on
the boat and the other people said they
did and she said i do and i said i do
and then the third time when she
said i want to get on the boat i just
looked at her and i see this i'm like
she's 23 and she's young and let her go
and how dare you
you know get in the way of her doing
this
and then she leaves and i'm immediately
like that is
classic you like you don't
you
look out for others to your own
detriment
you
constantly pour into other tanks and
you've been running on you for going on
a decade now that's not healthy it's not
healthy for any woman or mother or
person
and it was so
good for me to
see that like i don't think i saw it i
just lived it and saw like it is okay
to take care of yourselves and to
want something and go for it and you're
not a horrible person
if that means that someone else doesn't
get to do it right like that's huge and
i what do you ask for more than that i
mean that's life-altering i'm still
working on it it's hard because it's
ingrained i mean i'm gonna be 48 this
month it is ingrained in my way of life
yeah and i i'm i'm so grateful that i
can see it and challenge myself in that
way it's amazing to see you growing and
it's amazing to see you realizing these
things about yourself
so another question from twitter you
touched on this earlier but i'd love to
hear more about it polly asked if
jackson leaving the game
affected your game at all yeah it it did
uh definitely he was my
that was that was my guy that was my
alliance we were a one-year part in age
we just we got each other we clicked um
personalities are very similar we're
both easy going you know um yeah i
yes i you know i say yes but again we
don't know i
i got the sense that and especially
after seeing the sneak peek or the the
hidden scene that
once jonathan found him looking for the
idol that had we lost it would have been
him going home which you know would have
been just postponed
my vote out
but also maybe giving me time to you
know start to play
yeah like really play so you know
there's so many different scenarios but
i do think it affected and i think i i
think in the moment i was
yeah i think i was
i was
it affected my mood
yes so yeah
well now you get to watch the show and
enjoy it with everybody else so who are
you rooting for to win survivor 42
i
have um
three people that i am rooting for i
hope in um
one from my tribe is omer he's just
spending that five days with him and
he's just got this
he just fall in love with him and he's
just such a neat personality so
um
jonathan i i think he encompasses so
much of the physical but not just the
physical i mean he's a good guy
i i'm also rooting for chanel
um who i've never had a conference i
never met her you know anything i've
never had a conversation with her but
there is something um
i don't know i just i i really
there's something spiritual there's
something very powerful i just just a
force i just
i you know i would hope um one of those
three would win that would be my hope
well mariah thank you so much for going
out there and playing i feel like you're
an inspiration to many and i feel like
your story and your brother's story are
going to really stay with us for a long
time so thank you so much i loved
speaking to you today
thank you so much and congratulations
for everything you got a lot going on
yeah i'm a busy one
all right thanks mariah